The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: We're really lucky
to have a guest lecturer, David
Tames today, who is a very
talented and experienced
videographer and cinematographer
with a vast array
of experience, everything
from pioneering web
video through feature
films and in between.
Also, he's a well-known tech
guru who has a well-regarded
blog, kino-eye.com.
He's a graduate
of MIT's Media Lab
and currently an
instructor at MassArt.
And he's going to
take us through some
of the basics of lighting.
And we're then going
to do a demonstration
of basic interview
three point lighting,
which should be a lot of fun.
So take it away, David.
DAVID TAMES: Glad to be here.
Thanks, Chris.
So as Chris said, we're going
to talk about basic lighting.
And we're going to use a simple
straightforward interview
as the subject of our
lighting discussion.
Today, of course, there's a lot
of things that we can light.
But basically, interview
lighting will be our focus.
Just since we're at MIT, we
need to talk a little bit
about what light is.
It's a tiny sliver of the
electromagnetic spectrum
that our eyes are sensitive to.
As the wavelengths
get shorter, you
end up with things like
X-rays and gamma rays.
And as the wavelengths
get longer,
we end up with radio waves, just
like this wireless mic going on
here.
But this tiny, tiny, tiny sliver
of the electromagnetic spectrum
is what our eyes happen
to be sensitive to.
And this is the medium
that we are working with.
These are our materials that
we work with in film and video.
And of course, there's
that classic experiment
that Newton did in his--
I guess it was his
grandmother's barn or something.
Not only did he--
it was well known
at his time that you
could break white light
into the constituency
of the various colors
of the rainbow.
But he also showed that once you
broke it down to those colors,
you couldn't break
it down any further
and that with a second prism,
you could recombine that light
back into white light.
So it turns out that working
with any combination of red,
green, and blue light, we
can create any of the colors
that we're sensitive to.
And so interestingly enough,
most of our imaging systems
today basically work with red,
green, and blue receptors,
which we will talk about
why red, green, and blue
happens to be the star colors
from which all other colors can
be derived.
And it turns out that our
eyes have receptors sensitive
in the blue range, the green
range, and the red range.
And we are most sensitive
to those in the green range.
Perhaps our ancestors
who could see green
were more successful
than our ancestors
who were primarily sensitive
to other frequencies of light.
Who knows about that.
But enough technical stuff.
When we talk about
light creatively,
we're not thinking
about wavelengths
and the individual
colors that much,
but we're thinking about
certain characteristics.
We often talk about intensity,
how bright is the light.
And it turns out that since
most light sources radiate
in all directions, there's very,
very rapid falloff of light.
So we call that the
inverse square law.
So if you're by a window and
you have a really, really nice
exposure, walking
away from the window
just a little bit is enough
to end up in darkness.
Because if you
double the distance
between the light
and the subject,
you only have one fourth
of the intensity as before.
So you're always working
against the inverse square law
in terms of the intensity.
So if you need your
light to be brighter,
you can always move it
closer to your subject
or get a bigger light.
We also talk about
the quality of light,
whether it's hard or soft.
Hard light has bold
shadows, crisp textures.
We'll look at an example
in just a moment.
And soft light has
a gentle contrast.
It's more diffused, typically
very soft or no shadows.
We often talk about
the direction of light.
Where is it coming from?
It refers to the
path of the light
from the source of the
light to our subject.
Is it coming from the
front, the side, the back,
under light, top light?
And we use these
terms to describe
where the light comes from.
And of course, color, like we
just saw in the previous slide,
it's the relative
mix of wavelengths.
And color is often motivated
by the light source.
So if we want to
depict a sunny day,
we use yellows and very,
very light blues and white.
It can establish mood.
So if we're going
to-- typically,
period pieces that take
places during the Renaissance
happen to have an
orange glow about them.
Just last night I
saw Goya's Ghost
and was reminded of how we seem
to depict certain time periods
with certain color palettes.
Perhaps since the primary light
source during the Renaissance
was candles instead of HMI
daylight balanced lights
like we have on film sets
today, it makes a lot of sense
that in the evenings, the
world was predominantly
this golden yellow.
PROFESSOR: Just want to add
one quick thing about that.
As a documentary
filmmaker who's often
working in available
light, just remember
that those qualities that
David just talked about
apply to available light
just as much as to lights
that you might set up.
So if you think about the
lighting in this room,
it's really important
to start getting
sensitive to those
exact same situations.
Where's the light coming from?
It's coming from
overhead lights.
So what does that mean
for the way things look?
What are the colors
of those lights?
Well, they're fluorescents.
But if you actually
look at the bulbs,
you see that they don't even
match from fixture to fixture.
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
Some of these over
here are yellow
and some of these over here are
more towards the white range.
PROFESSOR: Blue-white, yeah.
So those are the kinds
of things that you
start to become sensitive to,
even as a documentary filmmaker
working without lights.
And all of those
things, the harshness,
the quality of the light,
the intensity of the light,
the direction, the
color, are assessments
that you need to make even in
situations where you're not
actually controlling the light
with artificial light producing
instruments, like we're
going to work with later.
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
I mean, even when I
go to do an interview
and I'm doing a pre-interview
and talking to the subject,
I always say, can we talk
while we're walking around?
Because I want to look at
the light in the environment
and try to start with
something natural.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
DAVID TAMES: I mean,
just this weekend, we
were on Martha's Vineyard
doing an interview,
and we carted the lighting
kit in the trunk of the car.
We carried it around.
We took it across the ferry.
We carried this big,
huge lighting kit with us
wherever we went,
and I never cracked
it open because we were able
to find several positions to do
our interviews where
the lighting was
perfect and natural.
However, it was very
important for me
to know that if we didn't
find a beautiful spot,
we could accent what
we had and supplement
with additional light.
PROFESSOR: So one of the big
takeaways from this lecture
today isn't just how
to set up lights,
although that's very important.
But it's also how to assess
the light that you have
and how to make choices
about where you shoot things
based on that assessment.
DAVID TAMES: That's a
very important insight.
So very briefly-- and by the
way, a PDF with the slides
and a PDF with written notes
to go with each of the slides
will be available as
part of this package.
So I don't want to go
into too much detail here,
but there are two primary
light models that we use
when we're talking about light.
We often talk about
the additive model.
So I don't if you've been
to the Museum of Science,
but they have this
great exhibit where
they show three projectors,
blue, red, and green light.
And where those three projected
light beams intersect,
you end up with
white light, which
I remember being
around five years old
and seeing this
for the first time,
and I just thought
that was miraculous.
Like how can those three
colors become white?
Because my experience with
paints was so different.
But that's because my
real world experience
was the other lighting model,
which we'll get to in a moment.
But that was magical that you
could combine these colors.
It turns out if you combine red
light and its complement cyan,
you end up with
white light as well.
Because if you have equal
amounts of red, green,
and blue light, then we
see what we call white.
And so I would suggest
visiting the PDF documents
for the gory details.
Now, when we're
working with-- often,
we want to change the
color of a light source.
And we'll put something
called a gel over that light.
And when we're doing
that, we're using
what we call the
subtractive light model.
In other words,
we're filtering out
some of the wavelengths
and not others.
So it turns out that if you put
yellow, cyan, and magenta gels,
which happen to be the
complements of red, green,
and blue, but if you put those
three gels over a light table,
for example, you will
see that you end up
with this muddy brown
darkness where they overlap
because you have
pretty much filtered
out all of the light sources.
They're not perfect filters,
so that black will never
be totally black.
This is why in four color
printing of magazines
and newspapers, they use
cyan, magenta, yellow,
and black ink for
that extra blackness.
So that also uses the
subtractive system.
So you can either
use pigments or you
can use gels to subtract
particular wavelengths.
So for example, if my scene
was a little too orangey
and I wanted my light sources
to be a little less orangey,
I would be putting different
gradations of blue gels
over those lights, for example.
So that's the subtractive model.
And once you get to know
this, it makes perfect sense.
And we'll talk a little
more about blue and orangey
correction gels, which
we have a tendency
to use a lot in film video work,
because we're often correcting
or changing the light
from the cool blues
to the warmer orangey lights.
But that's the
subtractive model at work.
So it turns out
that video cameras
being technical devices,
they don't really
know what white is.
Some combination of red, green,
and blue wavelengths is white.
But your white might be
different than my white,
might be different than
that Sony camera's white.
So what we typically do when
we white balance the camera
is we point the camera
and hold up a white card.
And we push the
white balance button.
And we're telling the camera,
that particular combination
of red, green, and blue,
whatever it happens to be,
that's my white reference.
And now the camera
will display whatever
that card is as pure white.
Well, it turns out that
this relative balance
of red, green, and
blue, the camera
sees it as a technical
problem to solve.
And very often, the perfect
white balance of a camera
is often maybe a little too
clean, too dry, too perfect.
So a trick that I do
is I get something
called an eighth blue gel, which
is like a very pale blue gel.
And when I white
balance my camera,
I hold that pale blue
gel over the camera lens,
I press the white
balance button,
and I push away the gel.
And what have I done?
I have fooled the camera
into thinking that there's
more blue in the world.
And it compensates by
making the image a teeny bit
warmer, a little more orangey.
And flesh tones
look a lot better
with just a little
bit of warmth added.
So this is my
little bit of basil
in the sauce for a
slightly tastier image.
You will hear a lot of people
talk about color temperature.
This is a method that
is used to describe what
the color of a light source is.
We work so often in this orange
to blue to white dimension
simply because so many of our
artificial and natural light
sources are in that range.
For example, fire,
candle, matches,
they're all kind of orange.
Sunlight is very blue.
And so it turns out that color
temperature is basically,
what temperature do
you need to heat up
this theoretical black
body radiator in order
to get that color?
Well, it turns out in
practical everyday world,
that black body
radiator that you've
read in cinematography
books, the equivalent,
think of it as a tungsten
filament, as a light filament.
The more juice you put through
that filament, the less orangey
it is and the more
white it becomes.
Of course, at some point,
it explodes because it's
handling too much current.
But in theory, if you heated
it up to 9,000 degrees,
you would have the same color
as hazy sunlight, which is very,
very pale blue, almost white.
But if you bring the temperature
down to 1,700 degrees Kelvin,
you would have the nice,
orangey color of a match flame.
So this is this
temperature scale
from orangey on the
low temperature end
to almost perfect white
with a slight tinge
of blue on the high end.
There are two magic
numbers that you
hear in the world of white
balance, 3,200 degrees
Kelvin, which is the industry
standard for tungsten filament
incandescent lights.
It is the standard that for
almost 100 years, well, maybe
80 years, film emulsions
were matched to that color
temperature, so that something
lit under 3,200 degree
Kelvin light would look white.
There's also daylight
balanced films.
So consumer film
was usually balanced
to 5,500 degrees Kelvin.
And that's called
daylight balance.
So most electronic flash
is balanced for daylight,
and consumer film was always
mostly balanced for daylight.
And of course, now in the error
of video and digital imaging,
it's a little bit of a holdover.
But we still use these terms
because film lighting still
comes primarily in
two flavors, tungsten
balanced, quartz halogen lamps,
LED lamps, fluorescent lamps,
et cetera.
They're all available matched
perfectly 3,200 degrees Kelvin.
And a new generation of HMI
daylight balanced lights,
daylight balanced fluorescents,
daylight balanced LEDs,
they're available
matched perfectly
to 5,500 degrees Kelvin.
PROFESSOR: And also many
cameras that you may use have
preset white balance settings.
So there may be
one for daylight.
There may be one for tungsten.
And when you click it
to one of those settings
rather than create
the white balance
yourself, as David
just described,
essentially what you're
doing is the equivalent
of loading your camera with
an emulsion that's balanced
to one of those presets.
So 3,200 is, in theory,
perfectly balanced
for tungsten light.
And the daylight balance is
perfectly balanced, in theory,
for about 5,500, 5,600.
DAVID TAMES: And
it's handy, right?
When you buy
lighting instruments,
it's nice that they all
match for the most part.
Now, if we look at these
three little pictures
here, something to think
about, outdoor shadows
are predominantly blue.
If you shoot in shadow, you get
really, really bluish images.
To our eyes, it may
look perfectly neutral.
But to the camera,
it looks really blue.
Why?
Because shadows don't
have any direct sun.
All the lighting
in the shadow is
coming from the sky,
which is predominantly
blue due to the way that the
light waves are scattered.
The different wavelengths are
scattered a different amount.
And so the sky has a
tendency to be very blue.
In the middle picture, you
see here a mixed environment.
The interior lighting
in this museum
is tungsten
incandescent lighting,
but you have blue daylight
streaming through the skylight.
These are the most difficult
situations to shoot,
because you basically have
to split the difference
or find some happy medium
between the tungsten
lighting and the daylight
lighting because there's no way
to reproduce that
the way the eye
sees it unless you do some
trickery in post-production.
So often, we're
splitting the difference
between tungsten interior
lighting and daylight
streaming through windows.
On a big Hollywood
budget, you'd send a crew
to maybe gel those windows and
put orange gel over the windows
so that now everything
is perfectly balanced.
As documentary
makers, we typically
don't have a crew that can gel
windows and things like that.
And so in some ways, we have to
be much more creative in terms
of how we choose
where we're going
to set the white
balance for our scene.
And of course, sunsets
are extremely warm due
to the scattering,
again, the way
the light rays are scattered.
And they have a tendency
to be very, very warm,
very, very orangey.
And the more crap that
we put in the atmosphere,
the more gorgeous
sunsets we get,
which is the one thing I do miss
about living in Los Angeles.
We had intense,
beautiful orange sunsets.
So the smog is
good for something.
Let me relate this to
the color correction
that you're going
to see in post.
We talked about the
green-cyan dimension
and the green-magenta
dimension and the blue-yellow,
which is the dimension that
we're usually working with.
And when you're correcting
images in post-production,
it turns out that
the same dimensions
that we saw in the
additive color model
come to work here as well
because our LCD monitors
we're looking at, red,
green, and blue pixels.
And with our cameras, we have
red, green, and blue sensitive
sensors.
So if our scene is a little too
yellow or a little too blue,
we can simply adjust in
our color correction dial.
So if you can correct in
post-production these problems
with white balance, why do
we worry so much about it
while we're shooting?
The reason is you want
to get the white balance
right the first time when you
shoot because if the scene is
excessively blue or the
scene is excessively orange,
what happens is you're going
to overexpose the red channel
or overexpose the blue channel.
And what happens is once you
overexpose that color channel,
there's no information or detail
to bring back when you correct.
So you will always notice
that a properly white balance
scene, you can
fine tune the color
and get a very
rich, sensual image.
But if you shoot the
wrong white balance
and you go in to
correct, you're going
to notice that your
detail looks different
and your highlights don't have
the same texture and detail.
Because if you shot, for
example, daylight balanced
in a tungsten environment,
you have completely
whacked out the red channel
relative to the green and blue
channels.
So you do want to get it right.
Because having one
channel way overexposed,
that detail is lost forever.
So yes, you can correct in post,
but get at least a good middle
of the road starting
point in production.
I want to revisit
quality of light.
So on the left, we have a scene
that was shot on a cloudy day,
and it's raining.
And by the way, a little
trick, on a cloudy day,
you would never see
the raindrops on film.
So we cheated, and we put
a very bright HMI daylight
balanced backlight
behind the actors
so that you would
see the raindrops.
Otherwise, the lighting is
completely flat and diffused.
But we cheated by having
a little hard backlight
that you don't actually see.
And then the raindrops show up.
But a typical overcast day
has very, very soft light.
The light is coming from many,
many different directions.
And so you don't see
distinct shadows,
and it has a
particular maybe soft
or maybe even a
gloomy feel, depending
on the context of the scene.
Notice on the right
with direct sunlight,
you get very, very hard,
crisp, distinct shadows.
So it turns out
that what determines
the quality of hard
light versus soft light
has a lot to do with the
size of the light source.
So even though the sun is many
times larger than the Earth
because it's so far away, it's
effectively a point source.
And a teeny tiny point
source is going to give us
crisp, clean shadows.
Whereas on an overcast
day, the entire cloud cover
is like Mother Nature's
beautiful silk.
It's all light coming from all
sorts of different directions.
And it's soft.
And you can't beat the
beautiful quality of light
on a cloudy day.
And then you can add
a small accent light
for a little bit of
dimension, and you'll
get beautiful video images.
But harsh sunlight
is pretty hard
to deal with,
especially with faces.
But we'll talk about it when
we do the hands on demo.
We'll talk about how we
can deal with those issues
in bright, direct sunlight.
So this is a summary
in more detail
of what I've just talked about.
But I want to point out that
in terms of soft light sources,
we're looking at things
like soft boxes, which
have a large diffusion material
in front of a hard light
or light bouncing off
of a white surface.
This is how you create soft
light because you can't always
order in a cloudy
day and cloudy days
don't always walk into
the building with you.
So you may have to
create that soft light
with an artificial unit.
Hard light, typically direct
sunlight, a Fresnel instrument,
any kind of open face
light with a reflector,
is going to give you hard light.
What's nice, though, is you
can always soften a hard light
by throwing diffusion
material in front of it, which
spreads the beam.
So it's always great to
have hard lights in your kit
because you can
always soften them.
But once a soft light unit,
there's really no practical way
to make it hard again.
Now, something that--
we are entering
this world of 3D cinematography
and all of that great stuff.
But it turns out that
for a zillion years,
photographers, painters,
cinematographers,
have been creating a
sense of three dimensions
without two cameras
and two lenses
but using light to do it.
And the trick is to create
these alternating areas
of light and dark and
light and dark in a scene.
And the great prince of
chiaroscuro was Caravaggio.
Caravaggio basically
introduced black
into the painter's palette and
created these really dramatic
three dimensional effects
by alternating light
and dark and light and dark.
And we often talk
about Rembrandt
lighting in portraiture.
And that little triangle in the
cheek opposite the light source
is one of the trademarks
of Rembrandt lighting.
And it's not really
about the triangle.
But what the triangle
means is that,
once again, we've
created the sense
of light on the side of
the face and then darkness
behind the nose and then
another area of light
and then another
area of darkness.
And those alternating
areas of light and dark
create this sense of dimension.
So by simply moving the
direction and the quality
of your primary
light source, you
can go from flat daytime
soap opera lighting
to dimensional dramatic
front line interview
or Rembrandt portrait lighting.
And it's all about
the quality of light
and what direction
it's coming from.
And Rembrandt and Caravaggio
offer a wonderful study
in classic chiaroscuro lighting.
So let's talk about a few
practical, real world, almost
run and gun but not quite,
carrying three lights
interviews.
So here's a frame from a film.
The lighting is a little more
dramatic than you usually see.
I have a tendency to err
on the side of drama.
We sort of have that
little Rembrandt triangle
on her cheek.
And we can see that
there's alternating
areas of light, dark,
light, dark in this frame.
So how do we create this?
What did we do?
So if we look behind
the scenes, we
see that we have a primary
light source, a soft box.
The primary light
source is typically
called the key light,
our primary light source.
It's off to the side.
It's creating that
sense of dimension.
To the right, we have what's
called the fill light.
Whatever light is filling
in the shadows created
by the key light, we
call that the fill light.
And in the case of this example,
we're using a reflector.
It's called a Flexfill, which
you'll see in the live demo
portion of our show.
We're using a Flexfill to
reflect some of that key light
back onto the subject so that
the dark side of the face
doesn't become totally dark.
And then slightly off the
top of the frame there,
we have a backlight.
And we're using the backlight
to create a little bit-- if we
go back to this image,
there's a little bit
of light on her shoulder.
And there's a little
bit of light on her hair
that's coming from behind her.
So what we did is we
have a 300 watt Fresnel--
we'll talk a little more
about Fresnels later--
behind her that's just
giving a little bit
of light coming
from the back, which
creates a little bit of
additional dimensionality
and separation from
the background.
But in this particular
frame, it's very subtle.
If you overdo the
backlight, all of a sudden,
things start to look theatrical.
We're in the middle of a play.
We're not in the middle
of a documentary anymore.
So you have to be careful
because the backlight is a very
artificial element.
But if done subtly,
it can look very much
like a natural element and give
a little bit of separation.
And we can see a little
bit of shine in the hair.
And then we have a fourth light.
Because remember, we've got
the key light, the fill light,
filling in the shadows caused
by the key light, a backlight
coming from behind
the subject, offering
a little bit of dimension.
And there's a fourth light
that we often talk about,
and that's the background
light, not to be
confused with the backlight.
Now, the background light
in this particular scene
is being provided by the window
in the upper right hand corner.
I've covered up part of
the window with foam core,
but I've left the
rest of the window
open to add this overall light.
So if we go--
oops.
If we go back here, the
overall ambient light
that's lighting the
back wall is a mixture
of what's coming
in from the window
and what's coming in
from the key light
because we don't want
the background-- we want
the background to be a little
bit darker than the subject
so the subject pops out
as the main element.
Because one of the
things that we're
thinking about when
we're lighting is we're
drawing attention.
We're using lighting to draw
the viewer's attention to what
the important things
are in the frame.
But we don't want to
completely obscure
the background, because while
the interview subject may
be the subject of our image,
there's also a predicate, just
like any good sentence.
And so the context here
is the editing room,
is the equipment
that's in the room.
So we want to feature that, too.
But we want it to feel like
it's part of the background,
both in terms of intensity
and in terms of placement.
So a little bit of
background light
is being provided by
both spill from the key
as well as some of the windows.
So what we did is we
varied that foam core
until we had just the right
amount of ambient light
in the room.
And that's where we placed it.
So very often, you can
use nature, natural light,
as one of your light units.
I like to work with
what's natural.
I knew that was
facing in a direction
that we wouldn't have direct
sun shining in the room
any time during the interview.
So it's always good to know what
direction the sun's going in.
So we could rely for
two hours that we
would have skylight
but no direct sunlight
to mess up our scene.
So if I can bring Mother Nature
into the lighting equation,
that's great.
If I could do this whole setup
without any artificial light,
that would be even better.
But that doesn't always
work out that way.
So I'm going to basically
review what we just talked about
in four different environments.
So a typical formal interview
is what you just saw.
In this particular
situation, I saw
that there were these beautiful
French doors in the room.
I said, aha, we're going to
use that as our background
because it looks nice.
It adds a little
bit of dimension.
But I want the
background to recede,
and I want the foreground
to move forward.
Well, it turns out that your
warmer colors have a tendency
to move forward, and your
cooler colors, like your blues,
have a tendency to fall
into the background.
So what did I do?
I put a background light
behind the lace curtains,
behind those French doors,
with a half blue gel.
So that's giving me
the bluish background.
And of course, she's
being lit by a soft box,
something called a
Rifa-Lite from Lowel.
So the primary key in this case
is a relatively medium sized,
I guess, soft light.
And once again, we're using
the reflector Flexfill
as our full light because the
less wires and the less light
that I can travel
with, the better.
So we basically lit this
situation with two lights
plus the ambient
spill that was coming
from the windows in
the middle of the day.
So this was, once again, a
three point lighting setup,
but we're only
using two fixtures
because we're making use
of the natural light that
was available in this
living room at the time.
And the key is relatively soft.
And you can tell that
by the way the light
wraps around the face.
So notice how even
though that there's
a shadow where her
nose is and there's
a shadow on the right
hand side of her face,
there is a smooth gradient from
the light to the dark area.
And we call that the way the
light wraps around the face.
We'll see now in
this other interview,
we have a harsh,
overhead, standard Edison
based light bulb, 150
watt screw-in light bulb
in the top of the room.
There's also a couple
of small quartz lights
that are lighting the toy
collection cabinet behind her.
But this is basically
working under very harsh,
non-optimal lighting conditions.
And so it's not at all
flattering in some ways.
We're not doing our
subject justice.
Of course, in this
film, she was playfully
playing the role of the bad guy.
So the lighting
worked dramatically
for those purposes.
So I decided to go
with it rather than
bringing the lighting kit out
because we said it looks OK.
We want this to
be raw and harsh.
Once again, it's
all about context.
What does the lighting
do for your storytelling?
It was OK for a character
making certain harsh comments
to be in slightly harsh light.
At least it worked
for me creatively
in this particular scene.
But most of the time,
that's not what I want.
Here's another situation
which is not at all optimal.
This is handheld,
impromptu conversation
with a character in the
middle of an art opening.
The lighting was
mixed, window light,
dark corners,
incandescent lights,
harsh, really, really difficult.
I looked around the room,
and I go, oh my God,
what are we going to do?
And then I saw this big window.
And I said, do you mind
standing next to the big window?
So out of the darkness, I
was able to move the subject
so that she was being
lit by window light.
So here's me, no lights, no
kit, camera in my right hand,
microphone in the left hand.
Let's move by the window.
So sometimes, you just
got to look around
and see where the
light looks best
and move your subject
into that area.
PROFESSOR: And it's
remembering, again,
to apply some of the principles
that you're talking about
in a situation where
you don't have lights
but still keeping in
mind all of the things
that we're discussing, the
intensity of the light,
the direction of the light,
the quality of the light,
the color of the light,
and making choices on where
you conduct your interviews
or do your shooting--
DAVID TAMES: Exactly.
PROFESSOR: --based
on those principles.
DAVID TAMES: In
fact, in this case,
I didn't even have time
to do my 8th blue trick.
I just set the
preset to daylight
because I knew that the window
was pretty much daylight.
And of course, you're
getting the little bit
of triangle on the cheek
because of her position
relative to the light.
So that is what I'm always
paying attention to.
I watch somebody
talking, and I go,
am I seeing that
dimension light?
And in fact, when I'm doing an
impromptu interview like this,
I won't ask the
subject to change.
Very often, I will
move and watch
how the lighting
changes on their face.
Because sometimes just moving
to the left a foot and a half
or to the right
a foot and a half
will completely
change the lighting
when somebody moves their
face like this to look at you
or like this to look at you.
So those are the
things that you want
to get in the habit of
always thinking about.
It becomes this automatic
background process,
sort of like background
rendering or whatever.
And of course, I do like
dramatic chiaroscuro sometimes.
This was a particular moment
where the character is talking
about how he first
came to Boston
and he found it to be a
cool and uninviting place
and people weren't
very friendly.
And so even though most of
the interviews in this film
are shot in natural
light, I decided
to shoot this one
dramatic and dark.
This is where the
character starts
to realize certain things.
And it's a very personal,
intimate moment.
So we said, OK, let's do
the more chiaroscuro thing.
So you have the light
coming from the side.
And we're using actually
pretty relatively intense
blue back lights
for the background
so that the background
doesn't go totally black.
But it's relatively dark.
So this is a little
more along the lines
of Caravaggio versus Vermeer.
PROFESSOR: And you can also
see the theatricality that you
were talking about before.
DAVID TAMES: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I mean, it might work
for this subject in the case.
DAVID TAMES: Right.
It worked in this case.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
DAVID TAMES: And it's
really the only interview
in the entire film
that's lit this way.
This was kind of a
brief, theatrical moment
in some respects.
But yeah, it has
that theatricality.
It's not at all natural.
This is of somebody feeling
like a fish out of water.
I wanted to create an image
that didn't feel like it
fit with the rest of the film.
So these are four
different approaches
to an interview situation.
And if you take a
look at the PDF,
I've synthesized what I have
found from seven or eight
different sources,
basically, as you
change the position of the key
light relative to the subject,
you go from this continuum from
glamor lighting on the left,
where the key light
and the fill light
are actually directly
overhead, there's
a small little butterfly
shadow under the nose
and there's a fill
light filling that
in so it's not a harsh
shadow under the nose
and this kind of
Hollywood lighting
where the key is almost
in front of the subject.
It gives you this very
glamorous look, especially
if you have high cheekbones.
But it's not at all natural,
but it is very glamorous.
And then as you move the
fill light to the left,
in the middle here, you
get to the Rembrandt style,
which is my tendency.
I like the light
coming from the left.
I also find in situations where
I'm using a small hand-held LED
light to give a little bit
of supplemental lighting
in an otherwise verite
situation, if I put
the light to the
left of the subject,
not only do they look
better and more dimensional,
but it's not glaring
in their eye.
And that's actually
more comfortable.
And then, of course,
profile lighting,
basically the key is
behind the subject
and you're emphasizing
their profile.
I mean, that's really dramatic.
You would do that
for an interview
with somebody whose identity
you want to obscure.
You kill the fill light,
and you have a backlight
coming from the back.
And you just see this
outline rim of a person.
What this slide is about
is to encourage you--
when I've taught a detailed
cinematography class,
I actually have the
students set of these
up and shoot all
these different setups
and reflect on how the
lighting changes as you
move the key light around.
It'd be cool to have a 3D
simulator environment to try
these things out.
But there's nothing like
going out into the real world
with your lighting kit and
trying these different setups.
So we've talked
about soft light.
We've talked about hard lights.
Some common lights that you find
available in the market today,
there's a variety
of soft lights.
They're very popular,
since if you're
going to do a simple,
quick, and dirty interview
with a single light,
typically you'll
just pull out a soft light.
A popular soft
light is something
called the Lowel Rifa.
It kind of pops open
like an umbrella.
You throw a diffuser
on the front,
you hook it up to the stand,
and it sets up very quickly,
and instant soft light.
Although they're a
little more expensive,
I love the Kino Flo Diva Lite.
This is a fluorescent light
fixture that has four,
or two depending on the
size, fluorescent bulbs.
And you can pop
in either daylight
balanced fluorescents or
tungsten balanced fluorescents.
I've done a lot of interviews
outdoors, under a tree,
in the shade, and
brought in the Diva
with the daylight
balanced light just
for a little bit of
sparkle in the eyes,
just for a little bit
of extra definition.
And all of a sudden, it takes
something in the shade and soft
and gives it just a little
bit of dimensionality.
And you can't do that
unless your light source
is daylight balanced.
And the Diva is just
barely bright enough
to use in the shade.
No light source is
going to work in the sun
unless you have a
Hollywood grip truck.
But for indoor interviews,
a couple of Divas
is just spectacular
in terms of soft light
with just a little
bit of directionality.
And the fact that you
can pop in and out
the fluorescent light tubes
for either daylight or tungsten
is really awesome.
It comes in a little suitcase
with both sets of bulbs.
And off you go.
Open face lights are
much less expensive.
They're relatively
cheap, anything
from a $30 work light at Home
Depot to a Lowel Omni-Light.
They come in all sorts
of shapes and sizes.
Typically, they have
a parabolic reflector.
And then we'll talk in
a moment about Fresnels.
Fresnels are a little fancier.
They actually have
a lens system.
PARs-- and of course, what
you see here in the picture
is a PAR with a soft
box on top of it.
PARs are very
efficient light sources
because they have this
parabolic reflector built
in to the light unit.
And they're often available in
this high technology, daylight
balanced light called an HMI.
Small PARS in the
300 watt range are
very popular with
documentary crews
because you can power
them off a small battery.
Their daylight balance,
you can use them
outdoors to get rid of
shadows and stuff like that.
And then if you
need to soften them,
you can always pop a
soft box in the front.
Or if you need
that hard intensity
efficiency of the PAR unit, you
can just pull the soft box off.
So they're very versatile
in that respect.
And in fact, here in Boston,
the local rental house rents
something called a Kobold.
Did I say that right?
Kobald?
Small, HMI PAR, which
is really useful.
But if you're on a tight
budget, you don't necessarily
have to go out and spend
thousands of dollars
on professional lighting.
Mother Nature usually provides
her services for free.
You can use practical
household bulbs.
Popular among some folks are
simple photo flood lamps,
which are very bright
incandescent lamps that you can
put in inexpensive fixtures.
It turns out, fluorescent
utility lights,
ordinary fluorescent
lights, you can actually
go to your local
hardware supply store
and buy daylight balanced or
tungsten balanced fluorescent
tubes, Chroma 50s and Ultra
32s I think they're called.
And you can put them in
ordinary fluorescent fixtures.
Chinese lanterns are awesome,
these paper little lanterns.
But I wouldn't use more
than a 60 or, pushing it,
100 watt bulb in these
paper lanterns and never
leave them unattended.
Regardless of how
flame retardant
the manufacturers say they are,
I wouldn't leave them alone.
But they give you this
beautiful soft light.
Now, there's a
professional version
of these lanterns
called Chimera lanterns.
And they're made of a special
high heat resistant material.
And you can put a pretty
powerful 1,000 watt lamp
inside one of those and get
this beautiful, beautiful soft
light.
But I've seen a lot of people
get a lot of mileage out
of ordinary work lights.
I know a lot of animation folks
use ordinary hardware store
work lights for their
lighting source.
You can clip a little diffusion
in the front if you need to.
They're cheap.
The only downside
is that they don't
fold up nicely for travel.
But if you're doing
animation work at home,
those inexpensive work
lights work great.
And you can actually buy
tungsten balanced 3,200 degree
Kelvin bulbs for them.
So on camera lights,
some people like them.
I personally don't
like on camera lights
because I really don't like
the flat look that they create.
I prefer to hold a camera off
to the side, find an assistant,
find somebody to hold the
light off to the side.
I've even done it myself.
Your arm gets really,
really, really tired.
But it pays off by
not having that deer
caught in the headlights
look of the light
directly on the camera.
People don't like being blinded.
Get the light off to the side
is the moral of the story.
But these small battery
powered lights, especially
the new generation of
light emitting diode LED,
lights are spectacular because
I've been able to shoot all day
with four camera batteries
and a couple of LED lights,
not on continuously,
but it can work.
I have a thing for Fresnels.
I really like the
quality of their light.
They were originally developed
by Augustine Fresnel,
who contributed to the
theory of color and optics.
And the French
Lighthouse Commission
had a problem in
the early 1800s.
Those whale oil lamps
weren't very bright.
Ships were going into rocks.
A lot of sailors and merchandise
was being lost at sea.
And they commissioned Fresnel
to solve the lighthouse problem.
Well, he realized,
you know what?
If we put a whole bunch of
these triangular pieces of glass
in the right
arrangement, we can take
all of those light rays
that are going astray
and send them all off,
single line, out to sea.
And all of a sudden, these
teeny tiny little whale
oil powered lamps
were super bright
because all of the light rays
are going single file where
they're supposed
to be out to sea
instead of lighting the
side of the lighthouse.
Who cares about that, right?
So what's interesting
about Fresnels
is that they're
very crisp, clean,
focus lights that cast
perfectly clean shadows.
They have the same quality
of light as direct sunlight.
They're great for backlights.
They're great for when you
want that quality of light
coming through the window.
They're a little heavier
and more expensive
because they have this
scalloped glass lens, which
you might recognize the pattern
from lighthouses, which we have
a lot of here in New England.
And so the units are
a little heavier.
But they have a little knob
where you can focus them.
And they have that nice,
crisp quality of light.
So I have a thing for Fresnels.
I really like them.
I own five myself.
But they are heavy
to carry around.
That's the price you pay.
They are physically bigger
and physically heavier.
Here's a chart comparing
different lighting
technologies.
Because not only do we have
different configuration
of lights, like open
face, soft light, soft--
open face Fresnels,
soft light, et cetera,
in terms of the
physical configuration
of the light source versus the
lens unit and things like that,
but there's basically
four technologies
that we use today in
professional lighting
for providing the
source of light.
Typical tungsten incandescent
lamps are the least expensive.
But they use up a lot of energy.
Unfortunately,
incandescent lights,
they are actually
space heaters that
happen to give a small
percentage of their energy
out in the light range.
But maybe 30% is light and the
rest of the energy is heat.
They're very hot.
And on a hot summer
day, they're just
really uncomfortable
to be close to.
HMI is newer
technology, daylight
balanced, very high tech units.
But they're expensive.
They require a lot
of electronics.
They require very sophisticated
lamps with rare Earth gases
and all kinds of fancy stuff.
But their daylight balanced.
And they're very bright
and very efficient.
Halfway in between
are fluorescents.
They make great soft lights.
They run very cool.
They're not necessarily the
best thing for the environment,
but neither are the
other lighting sources.
But they run cool, and
they use less power.
And the Kino Flo fluorescent
lights are just awesome.
And up and coming,
they are LEDs.
LEDs have come a long way
in the last few years.
They're available in these
panels of either daylight
balanced or tungsten balanced.
In fact, light panels
has a really nice grid
that's a bicolor panel.
It's a grid of both daylight
and tungsten balanced LEDs.
And you can dial in how
much you want of each.
There's also a small
version called the Blender,
which actually has
a grid of daylight
and tungsten balanced LEDs.
And you can dial in the
color temperature you want.
So they're very
expensive compared
to other light sources.
But they're very versatile.
The zeolite is a
model of LED light
that you can dial in
any color because it
uses a red, green,
blue grid of LEDs.
There's some really nice, new
products in the LED department.
And while they're
expensive, their lightness
is just awesome.
If you go all LEDs, you
can cut the weight and size
of your lighting kit in half.
So there's something to
be said for high tech.
If you're just starting out, you
don't have any lighting at all
and you'd like a little
something to start with,
one suggestion is an open
face light with an umbrella.
Lowel makes this light
called the Tota-Light.
And they also have a newer
version called the V-Light,
which is a little safer.
But this is basically just
an open face light unit.
And used with an umbrella
bouncing the light,
you can now have a choice
between a hard light
or a soft light.
And so you can get a very
quick and easy lightweight,
soft source by bouncing
the Tota off the umbrella.
And there's your soft light.
And you can put
this kit together,
including a small light
stand, for less than $250
from your favorite
online equipment retailer
or your local photo shop
that sells video and lighting
equipment.
So this is the Lowel
Tota-Light or the Lowel V-Light
as a great starter kit.
You can put this in
a teeny duffel bag.
I've often taken something like
this with me on the train down
to New York, camera on one
shoulder with sound gear
and this on the other shoulder.
Very light, simple, effective.
Then over time, you might
want to add additional units
depending on your
particular lighting style.
A lot of people ask me, what
lighting kit do you recommend?
Well, it's really hard for me
to recommend a lighting kit
because it really depends
on what your preferences are
and what you want to accomplish.
So I would suggest buy
one light at a time,
learn it, get to know it, and
figure out what you want next.
Start with a basic soft
light and go from there.
You might want to
add some Fresnels.
add some LED lights.
You might want to add a
Flexfill reflector, which you'll
see in the live demo portion.
So these are various things
that you might want to add.
But explore.
Use it, and figure
out what you need.
A lot of towns
have rental houses
that you can rent light kits,
rent a kit for a weekend,
get to know it,
decide what you like,
what works for you, what
doesn't work for you.
Just remember, it all starts
with a good key light.
So definitely at
some point, you want
to have something
like a Lowel Rifa-Lite
or a Kino Flo Diva Light
as your staple soft light.
And then we talked
about diffusion material
that you can get.
It sort of looks like opaque
gel that will soften any light.
That's why it's nice to have a
few hard lights because you can
always soften them with gels.
Color changing gels,
there's this whole series
called CTB for Color Temperature
Blue, CTO for Color Temperature
Orange.
You can use these
gels for changing
the color of light sources.
Black wrap is an
interesting material.
It's aluminum foil with
flame retardant black paint.
You can use that--
if light is spilling
from a light unit,
you use the black wrap to
kill the spill off the light.
And you won't start any fires
because it's flame retardant
and it's metal foil.
Does get hot though.
And several manufacturers make
these great little wrapping
things called jelly rolls that
you can roll up your gels in.
And they come in both
small and large sizes.
Dimmers are handy
for dimming lights.
But I'll warn you now that they
create 60 cycle hum and buzz.
And very often, the filament
of lights will buzz.
So if you carry
dimmers on the set,
if you're working
with a sound person,
they will talk to you about it.
So dimmers are
useful, but they're
tricky because of the
interference problems.
But in some cases,
they can be used.
Cube taps are useful for
turning one outlet into three.
You want to be careful
with those two prong
to three prong adapters.
But in a lot of
older houses, they
don't have three prong
plugs, my own included.
Gloves are handy if you--
I usually handle
lights without gloves
because I know exactly
where the hot parts are
and where the hot parts aren't
from years of experience.
But when you're
starting out, you
might want to use
gloves and be careful.
Gaffer tape will
solve any problem
that the lighting instruments
can't solve in most cases.
And I won't go into detail,
but as you expand your lighting
work, you might want to add
things like flags and nets
for sculpting light.
But that's beyond the
scope of this talk.
If you ever have
larger lights, you're
going to need to put
sandbags on the stands.
So having some portable
beach is very, very handy.
And there's the
universal C-stand
that can be used for
all sorts of things,
hanging sound blankets
in addition to
holding lights and stuff.
And there's a lot of
gripology that we're not
going to get into today.
But it's good to know that
there is this whole collection
of gear out there.
But some that are
useful is if you're
working in an environment
with drop ceilings,
these little scissor
clamps are great,
which will give you a
standard 5/8 inch stud
for hanging a small light.
It's good to have a couple
of those in your kit.
Mafer clamps are very handy,
also known as photo clamps
depending on who you ask.
These are great
clamps that you can
attach to pipes and all sorts of
conduit and things if you need.
You'll notice that
for all small lights,
the industry standard
is a 5/8 inch stud.
It's also known as a baby stud.
Grip clips are great.
You can buy official grip clips.
You can go to the hardware
store and buy the equivalent
for a fraction of the price.
I still use a light
meter sometimes
when I'm setting up lights.
But it's probably
an anachronism.
Though it is handy to
have an 18% grade card,
white on one side
for white balance,
gray on the other side.
Very often, if you're
color correcting a scene
and you put that gray
card in the scene,
and now you have
a gray reference.
So if you're color
obsessed like myself,
you might want to carry
a gray card in your kit.
And there's a list
here of other things.
This is sort of a
homework assignment.
Figure out what all
these things are.
It's a good thing to learn.
At the end of the
day, just remember,
there are no rules about what is
good lighting and bad lighting
because one person's bad
lighting is another person's
dramatic lighting.
It might be bad if it
creates the wrong ambiance
for the scene or produces an
unintended unflattering effect
or it distracts the
viewer's attention.
Remember, we were
talking about we
use light to drive the viewer's
attention in the scene.
But if it's not doing that,
then maybe it is bad lighting.
Does it prevent the viewer
from seeing what's important?
Or is it showing things
that are irrelevant?
So one of the biggest problems
with point and shoot video
is that oftentimes our
subject is obscured,
and something that's
completely unimportant
is staring us right at the face.
So think about, what
is it doing for you
and your own storytelling?
Good lighting allows us
to do many, many things.
I'm not going to go
through this whole list.
But once again, it can
help us draw attention
to what's important
in the scene.
It can help isolate the subject.
It could imply a season.
It could establish a locale.
It can concentrate attention to
a particular part of the scene.
It can emphasize form, like we
talked about with chiaroscuro.
Or we can de-emphasize
form with flat lighting.
At the end of the
day, it about altering
the viewer's emotional response
and establishing a mood.
And so here's kind of my
laundry list of all the things
that lighting can do for you.
And through experience
and through practice,
you will see how what
you do with lighting
has an impact in
your storytelling.
So that's a list
of all the things
that lighting can do for you.
And at the end here,
there's a brief glossary
of terms of
enlightenment, which is
a word I borrowed
from Ross Lowell, who
wrote a wonderful book called
Matters of Light and Depth,
which I highly recommend.
There's electricity
involved in lighting.
And you want to be very careful
and treat it with respect.
And if you have frayed
wires or anything damaged
in your lighting
equipment, you want
to fix it before you
plug it into the wall.
What you have here is a simple
calculator for determining,
do you have enough power
to provide the power
for your lighting units?
So the way to remember it is
a 20 amp circuit, a 20 amp
household circuit, which is
pretty standard in bathrooms
and kitchens in
contemporary construction--
in a lot of older houses, you
will find 15 amp circuits--
but the thing to
remember, a 20 amp circuit
can support 2,000 watts.
That's the only number
you need to remember.
And you can
extrapolate from there.
A 20 amp circuit can
feed to 2,000 watts
because you just basically take
the amps and multiply by 100.
Amps are basically a measure
of how much current, how
much oomp, you're drawing
from that circuit.
And the wattage of a
lamp, 2,000, 100 watts,
is how much energy that
lamp is putting to work.
So the important
thing is that you
don't want to draw more
current from the circuit
than it can take because then
you'll pop the circuit breaker.
So whenever you set
up a lighting kit,
if your total lighting
kit only uses 1,500 watts,
you probably don't have
to worry about popping
an ordinary breaker.
But you want to know where the
breaker box is just in case.
And whenever I go
into somebody's home
to do an interview or
whatever, I always ask them,
do you have anything plugged
in that if the power went out
would cause some of disaster?
Always ask.
There are times,
for example, when
I've run extension
cords into a kitchen
to power an interview
in a living room
because somebody had
their computer set up
and they didn't want to
turn it off and whatever.
You just don't want
to mess with it.
But the thing is, in
modern construction,
you can always count on
a solid 20 amp circuit
in a kitchen or a bathroom.
And usually, there's nothing
else plugged into that circuit.
So this will go into some
safety tips, common sense,
that you should read.
And I mentioned a good
resource for further study
is Ross Lowell's wonderful book
Matters of Light and Depth.
To date, it's the best book
ever written about lighting.
It's written from the point
of view a lot of experience.
And what's interesting
about Ross Lowell
is he has done a lot of shooting
with a minimal amount of gear.
And it's written from the point
of view of getting the most out
of the least amount of
gear in terms of lighting.
And Ross Lowell developed
a company, Lowel-Lights,
to sell his--
at the time, he developed
a whole new generation
of lightweight
lighting units, which
were very popular
among documentarians
who didn't want to carry
around big equipment cases.
They wanted to carry around
small equipment cases.
And it's also written with
a wonderful sense of humor.
You will chuckle while
you read this book.
So Matters of Light and
Depth, highly recommended.
And there's also a lot of
wonderful resources online.
dvinfo.net is a wonderful
discussion group for matters
of a technical nature.
And selfreliantfilm.com is a
wonderful blog about making
films do it yourself style,
which I highly recommend.
And that's it.
PROFESSOR: So just to
wrap up, the second half
after a short break is
going to be the demo.
And a lot of the things that
David talked about and showed
in the PowerPoint will
become a little bit clearer
as we go through the demo.
But just to wrap up,
a lot of lighting,
especially lighting on our
level, beginning and low,
no instrument
lighting, boils down
to just learning
how to see things.
And it's so much
like other things
in shooting, framing, learning
how to shoot for an edit.
You really need to practice
seeing what's actually there
and thinking about how that is
going to affect your audience.
You're the first
audience for your film.
So all of the things that
David talked about at the end
really boil down to
seeing what's there
and learning how to make
a determination about what
needs to be changed in order
to get the image that's
going to have the impact
that it needs to have.
So often, and I think I've
said this before, but so often,
even people who have been
doing film for a long time
sometimes fall into
the trap of forgetting
that you can actually make a
change because it's difficult
or it's imposition is
problematic for somebody.
But if it really is necessary
to make some kind of change,
it's really up to you to do it.
So if you're shooting in a room,
doing an interview in a room
or in a location
that's not going
to work because the lighting
just is impossible to do,
if the person standing
in a place that is just
going to be a disaster,
you need to make a change.
You need to ask them
to move somewhere else.
And using your experience
and your sensitivity
to what the situation is based
on some of these things David's
talked about, these
basic principles,
then determines where
you get them to move to,
what change you actually
affect in order to get
the image that you need to get.
So that's it.
I think the second
part of this is
going to be really fun because
we're going to see some
of these principles in action.
So thanks a lot.